I had a great shot blue skies totally
clear I tilt it up just as the GoPro on
the drone tilted down and I saw the red
light blinking which immediately told me
it's recording and there's a chip in
that camera but what I didn't know is is
the drone operator some worthless little
pervert within a mile of me looking at a
monitor is he recording it there as well
and this all goes through the reptilian
part of your brain very very quickly you
know but all you can really think of it
is if I pull that trigger and revel in
the satisfying tinkle of cheap plastic
falling down onto the deck is all of it
going to pop up on the internet you know
moments later hi I'm Nick Gillespie with
Reason TV and we are sitting down with
Mike Rowe of the microbe Works
Foundation and of recently if somebody's
got to do it and have dirty jobs Mike
Rowe thanks for talking to Reason TV
last time I saw you you were wearing
that same jacket and I was wearing this
same hat well there you go
you know what comes around goes around
now the two headlines that you are most
famous for most recently our naked micro
and micro dead what why were you naked
and how did that lead to you being dead
was a big week yeah um I was in the
midst of what I thought was some bizarre
gardening dream and in the dream a
bumblebee was in my ear and when I
awakened I realized it wasn't a dream
and B it wasn't a bee but there was a
buzzing sound and it was coming from the
other side of my bedroom window and I
left from the bed and what I described
as my favorite pair of imaginary pajamas
and I pulled the drapes aside and there
was a camera hovering not in midair but
from the belly of a drone and the drone
was making this horrible buzzing sound
and I was standing there and my horrible
nakedness not fully awake but but
sentient enough to know that something
had to be done so I retreated to the bed
pulled the Mossberg 500 from underneath
and by the way do you get a is that a
product placement it's not I just like
the way I feel when I say Mossberg 500
it's a great shotgun I keep it locked
and loaded
the familiar chunk chunk is very rare
this is in San Francisco so it is that
legal to have a locked and loaded
shotgun it's it's it's it's hard to know
but okay lis not so your now you're
naked with a shotgun right so so so
technically not naked don't clothes in
the security that can only come from the
Mossberg 500 and I'm assuming like most
gun owners you're now your fully erect
as well right because naturally gun was
an extension partially okay and to be
fair it's very difficult to tell in my
case the difference between me fully
erect and I'm lost burg 500 in whatever
state I happen to be in I I ran down the
stairs with the gun out onto the deck
and I looked up to where I had last seen
the drone the thing had actually hovered
in a little closer to the window so I
had a great shot blue skies totally
clear I tilt it up just as the GoPro on
the drone tilted down and I saw the red
light blinking which immediately told me
it's recording and there's a chip in
that camera but what I didn't know is is
the drone operator some worthless little
pervert within a mile of me looking at a
monitor is he recording it there as well
and this all goes through the reptilian
part of your brain very very quickly you
know but all you can really think of is
if I pull that trigger and revel in the
satisfying tinkle of cheap plastic
falling down onto the deck is all of it
going to pop up on the internet you know
moments later so I froze and the drone
flew away and I got one shot of it from
my iPhone and I posted that and your
Facebook page I did so has the footage
has not surfaced as of yet not to my
knowledge and I'm fairly we offer to you
to own the footage probably within 30 to
40 minutes
thanks you like that I'll direct you to
TMZ where I'm sure a healthy bidding war
will will unfold so how is that what
does that feel like because you know
we're libertarians and we kind of like
transparency but then this is also
obviously an invasion of privacy I mean
where do you you know I and that's a
good job right so
but he's working that thing it's a job
that you know they have sure look I
think the reason that goofy little post
was shared you know millions of times
was because on the one hand you know
it's a naked guy with a shotgun in San
Francisco so that there's something
there but but we're also talking about
this weird collision of privacy and
Technology and Second Amendment and all
these things that happen to be in the
headlines it seems on a fairly regular
basis are you what you're a big Second
Amendment guy or you like guns I'm a fan
of the Second Amendment you a fan of the
Bill of Rights I've I've grown up with
guns I've always had guns I'm not an NRA
guy not because I have anything against
them just because I'm not I'm not much
of a joiner what is it something that as
a gun owner or lifelong gun user you can
tell somebody like me or other people
who are uncomfortable about guns that
would make us feel more comfortable
about them I don't have a smart answer
but I will say that it's interesting how
you're either in the NRA or you're not
and I think that's a false division I
think the country is full of a lot of
false divisions right now and I think
there are a lot of people actually like
me who who aren't a member of the NRA
but do own a gun right who happened to
not be psycho killers and criminals and
those people I don't I think it's easy
to ignore them well hopefully right I
mean the psycho killers get all the
attention right or the nude guy yeah you
used to have a TV show with a shotgun on
the deck so you I mean that led to the
naked micro headlines and then there was
after that partly because you were
holding a gun there are these this rash
of micro dead two headlines and you
talked a little bit about that on your
Facebook page yeah I mean there can
still coming up probably what is it like
to have your death announced then and
not to be a South American dictator
where you know oh my god I better not
get up this morning um it's a this will
sound odd but it's it's it's it's it's
weirdly flattering you know because
because what comes back over then that
is a massive amount of concern
and curiosity from friends and family
and I don't wish to manipulate either
group but in Facebook land you've got
four million friends so people are just
rushing to find out you know is there
any truth to this and then you get to
like bathe in their relief right because
no no I'm alive and but most of all you
get to quote Twain well if in fact he
ever said it right
but proportions that the rumors of are
the reports of my death have been
grossly exaggerated did you lose any
friends over this because they finally
said what they thought about you all
along you mean you know that posted to
your page I am glad he's dead he's dead
in about time ya know but the cruelest
comments were mmm I thought he was gone
years ago that I guess was a bad F scott
Fitzgerald that's what was said about I
thought he died years ago that that's
tongue well speaking of which your show
on CNN somebody's got to do it which was
similar to Dirty Jobs where you went and
looked at hobbies and other tasks that
people did sometimes in extreme ways you
you worked on an aquatic show in in
Vegas you hung out with the goat cheese
the goat cheese queen of Humboldt County
California you did another water ballet
because you're a closet water ballet fan
that is now gone off the air that has
ended at CNN it has why did it end the
good news is it hasn't ended in it on
CNN we shot season four it's about two
reemerge somewhere else what happened
was the election and riots and terrorism
and natural disasters and all the
trouble in the world
yeah and you know I appreciate CNN
giving me an hour of prime time to tell
light-hearted stories about people who I
think are worth knowing right but it's
one thing to compete with everything
else on TV is another thing to compete
with all the trouble in the world
because you know you don't want to be
something bad happen somewhere and
people go to CNN you don't want to see
smart aleck in investigating the low
ride culture we're making cheese in
Humboldt County right with his tongue in
his cheek on the other hand if you're me
and you tell four million people hey you
know Tuesday night's nine o'clock and
I'm not on because you know Cuba just
opened up right okay so it's it was an
experiment and to some degree it's
working for some shows but Bourdain
who's doing a fabulous show is not you
know he's not doing he's not taking a
light-hearted look at anonymous people
you should know he's doing video essays
and reportage in foreign countries and
actually turn the sound down it looks a
lot like a CNN report and so it fits you
know I I just stuck out who are the
people that we should know oh you know
what what they do all sorts of different
things I mean this is you're famous for
your sheep castration stories of course
you know that guy yeah if people should
down that you know if you know anything
coming out of college you should know
how to use your mouth to castrate sheep
right but you know I mean they're you
you talk to a lot of people you boot
guys who work in septic tanks guys work
and sewers guys work you know hanging
from wires on bridges yeah what what do
the people that we should know that you
think we American should know happen
come well I think the most honest thing
I ever wrote was on a lunch bag before
the first episode of dirty jobs the
president of discovery at the time said
the show needs a mission statement and I
was like no God a mission statement
really I mean he's put a glass eye to
sleep with these things you know they're
just so earnest and dreadful but she was
right and what I wrote was my name's
Mike Rowe this is my job I explore the
country looking for people who aren't
afraid to get dirty
hard-working men and women who do the
kinds of jobs that make civilized life
possible for the rest of us dirty jobs
was about me finding those people
because I believe you should know them
somebody's got to do it was slightly
different that was a show about people
who I think you should know because they
wake up agitated they wake up convinced
that there's a better mousetrap
or their Don Quixote they're tilting at
windmills with her Sisyphus pushing some
rock up a hill and they're doing a thing
because they're compelled to do it and
those people I think are interesting for
a slightly different reason and these
are healthy obsession traffic this is
you it's not the psycho killer or no
maybe that's season 15 as serial killer
we're saving that for sweeps okay serial
killers yeah you should have of
different innards yes yeah what has
happened like have we become so
disconnected whether it's from people
who have you know a kind of compulsion
or a healthy obsession if I want to do
this this is my passion project or the
people who do the work
the hidden work that makes civilization
fun and nice and clean and and you know
just wonderful have we lost touch with
that in our society and if we have in
these these two dimensions what what's
the cause of that I think the irony of
the current level of disconnectedness is
directly a result of the current level
of connectedness I think for the first
time in history you and I are walking
around with a with a network in our
pockets you know it's not a phone or a
camera it's a network we can broadcast
we can we're more connected today than
we ever have been in what feels to me
like a superficial way but at the same
time if there was some sort of graph
that would indicate this I think we
would see a growing disconnect between
the average person and an understanding
of where food comes from where our
energy comes from and I know with food
you've talked about this it's it's
something like 1% or one and a half
percent of Americans are involved in the
producing of food so most of us we you
know it just shows up in the
supermarket's it shows up on our plates
it's magic yeah it's magic look the
modern agriculture is nothing short of
miraculous
but the work that's still done in areas
like artificial insemination and basic
animal husbandry is completely alien to
most people so the only way you feed 300
million people three times a day
through a marvel of effectiveness and
efficiency and so the modern farmer is
heroic and the modern farmer has an
image problem because the average person
addicted to chewing and swallowing still
sees them as Buck Owens or Roy Clark and
he halt playing a banjo and wearing
overalls and clear in the South 40 so
the same the same thing that has made
farming difficult well the military face
is one and a half percent of people
serve in the Armed Forces the the number
of tradesmen working right now is
actually very very small relevant to the
entire population and so we're
disconnected in my opinion from things
like food energy the prevailing
definition of a good job the most
fundamental things are infrastructure
even as we've become uber connected
literally to uber yeah of course I mean
it's it's it's just it's fascinating to
me
and clearly that's the price the the
unintended price we're paying of this
amazing level of connectedness is this
fundamental decoupling from what's
really important do you think the work
ethic suffers when because we're taking
for granted all of the marvels of the
world that you know we no longer live in
a world where when you flip a switch the
lights don't come on or it shorts out
and shocks you the way I would say it is
we no longer live in a world where when
you flick the switch and the lights do
come on your initial feeling isn't one
of wonder there is no initial feeling
you know the only feeling that comes is
when you flick the switch and the lights
don't come on and then isn't it amazing
how quickly we're outraged you know when
we flush the toilet and the crap doesn't
go away what what yeah what you know the
miracle of modern plumbing the miracle
of affordable electricity all these
things now we're just not sufficiently
gobsmacked and when we lose our sense of
wonder and our basic appreciation that
sets the groundwork for the eventual
disconnect that leads to vocational
education vanishing from high school
a widening skills gap contemporaneous
with spiking unemployment and all of
these seemingly dichotomous things that
leave people scratching their heads my
foundation takes the position that these
things aren't problems these are
symptoms of a larger wrestling and
confusion with what a good job is so
talk about the work ethic scholarships
in particular what is what is what
symptom or what underlying cause is that
trying to address or what symptom is a
treating I think that in the same way
certain people believe romantic
happiness will only happen when you
locate your soulmate I think a lot of
people today believe that vocational
happiness will only occur when you find
your dream job I think that's nonsense I
also think it's self-defeating because
it's just you know if you I identified
the existence of the proximate cause of
joy and then build giant barriers
between you and it you've just you just
made it very difficult to feel good so I
think a lot of people have done that and
I think I think work ethic suffers as a
result because it's been replaced by
this search ethic right I'm on the
search for the thing that will bring me
joy as opposed to no no it doesn't
matter what the job is you wake up early
you stay late
you take your bite of the crap sandwich
you make yourself indispensable you
master your job and then through pluck
and insistence and goodwill and humor
you run the joint in a year and a half I
still believe that can happen and all
dirty jobs I met a lot of people who
proved it so yeah there's a bit of
earnest horatio alger old man next door
get off my lawn coming from my
foundation but it's best I think
embodied in the sweat pledge which was a
product and that's an acronym so it's
not a it's not a pledge it's not like a
blood oath right now you know it stands
for skills and work ethic aren't taboo
right and it was the product of a
six-pack of Lagunitas
and careful reflection on my part on two
things the Boy Scout law mmm then you
are an Eagle Scout
yeah and the the 12 step recovery
process from Alcoholics Anonymous and
I'm and I'm I'm not a member of AAA but
I love the idea that there's a 12-step
process that might be applied to ideas
of personal responsibility and personal
accountability and workout and you guys
have at this point you've given out
something like four million dollars and
what what does that money go to and
where do you get it from the money comes
primarily from me
auctioning off the crap in my garage and
crap is also an acronym it's important
to always have acronyms that crap stands
for collectibles rare and precious right
so the idea was my garage is just full
of stuff
filthy mementos from my misspent career
and I take these mementos and I
autograph them and I try and tell an
amusing story and in the same way Jerry
Lewis would hope to guilt you to giving
money during a telethon by some sort of
performance I aim to raise money by
entertaining you and tell you what is
the most disgusting item that you've
auctioned off well depending on who you
ask
I just got 16 grand for an autographed
Donald Trump bat I was going to bring
that up but so there's that but then
talk about the semen okay
I collected semen collected semen for
many many many many many creatures
somebody's got to do it how to and from
a prize racehorses at a place called
Babcock Ranch in Texas and I collected
it with the help of an artificial vagina
and a baby bottle and you know when I
hear this story usually there's a guy
playing a whorehouse piano but so we
have one of those and you guys believe
in Vienna yeah you know the horses up on
a pommel horse literally you know
looking at what I can only imagine to
some video of black beauty or something
and
and a secretive roan inish Misty of
Chincoteague I got a bicycle helmet on
all right I look like a giant spencer
and i'm holding what appears to be a
water bottle which is an artificial
vagina and a baby bottle dangling from
the end you're gonna deflect with your
right hand and place the artificial
vagina all the way onto his penis and
then just hold steady yeah I believe
that horse is ready so I approach the
creature
I mean it's immigrant aid Alecto right
and I and I guide him into the
artificial vagina and hang on as he
expresses himself as only a you know one
ton animal can do in the heat of the
moment and his semen fills the baby
bottle and in the baby bottle is a is a
plastic container that houses it and
they use that usually to to fill many
pipettes which are subsequently injected
into the mayor's the broodmares
they let me keep this particular bottle
and I had it for many years in my
apartment it sat on the edge of the
mantle and in the afternoon deck the Sun
would come through and it would hit it
usually between 4:00 and 4:30 in a way
that would the Golden Hour it was it it
was so beautiful the way it was like a
prism right it was a semen inspired
prism and these little rainbows these
semen rainbows it would fill my living
room it was horrible
one year we had it on the Christmas tree
yes anyway I auctioned that off for many
thousands of dollars do you think that I
mean to be serious for a minute do you
think that we've lost the Wonder when we
encounter artificial vaginas where's the
you know we just get mad when they don't
work yeah I mean it is very very
frustrating to come home after a long
day knowing that the artificial vagina
you've been thinking of all day is
waiting for you and then to suddenly
find it's not that level of
disappointment
so the robe from Donald Trump you got
sixteen thousand five hundred dollars
for there's no accounting for taste
yeah yeah what happened was I announced
the end of somebody's got to do it on
CNN and I blamed Bernie Hillary
and Donald for sucking up all the
bandwidth which is actually kind of true
and then in a ps2 that post I said
listen if you guys feel guilty for
running me off the news network as
surely you must why don't you call up
something that I can auction off for my
foundation and I said Bernie send me one
of those crappy Blazers that rumpled
things you wear Hillary you she could
just coffee into a napkin cantos me
actually I invited her said to pantsuit
I even said I'd bottle it she did
it's Donald I said send me one of your
robes yeah because a couple weeks
earlier I auctioned off a ratty old robe
I've stolen from an overpriced spa in
Northern California and got like seven
or eight grand for and this is why you
were naked when you went out to shoot I
was Robley oh that's right I said I
simply didn't have time to dress for my
malfeasance but but of the three
Donald's people got back immediately
they said what do you want to get I say
send me a robe from the Trump Tower and
it said no problem
and I said and get him to sign it and
they said we'll run it by him two days
later it showed up signed there it is no
there it is that's his signature that is
his signature and he did this on the
campaign trail say what you will about
the guy he he understands the importance
of a story and he wasn't going to get in
his own way so he sent me the robe I put
the robe on I probably lost a million
friends because there I am wearing
Donald's robe right but I probably
gained a million too and you know the
bidding went up to 16 grand very quickly
we sent it out we used that money for
work ethics scholarships boom Bob's your
uncle
you're not going to endorse anybody for
president but how do you see the
politics of the moment this is you know
the craziest election do you worry about
the direction of the country beyond
these questions about work ethic and the
mismatch between jobs available jobs and
training for jobs Bernie or rather
Hillary Clinton and Donald Trump are
both very protectionist they talk a lot
about how trade deals are bad how does
that play into your worldview about
trade or jobs that are here and what not
is I mean I have a personal opinion on
it but but the honest and I think better
answer is how do you want to set the
table are we going to set the table in a
way that fundamentally advantages the
American consumer or are we going to set
it in a way that fundamentally
advantages the American worker and it's
not a rhetorical question it's already
been asking we've already answered it
we've set the table in a way that
benefits the consumer and I think we've
done it because they're more consumers
and workers all workers are consumers
writer not all consumers are workers so
we're in the global economy and you must
be this tall to get on the ride and
there's no negotiating we're in it right
now so you know that's the bargain we've
made and we're right now realizing that
maybe you know maybe that wasn't the
table we wanted to set after all but I
don't know how you put the poop back in
the goose you know I mean we we either
want to buy our Ford's for as little
money as possible then again another
product placement right I'm done with
folium I mean they're done with me but I
might come back around so I'm not going
to say anything too nasty no look I've
driven Fords all my life and I was proud
to speak on their behalf for a few years
but you know when Donald says he's going
to charge 35% more for a Ford that's
made in Mexico the crowd goes wild and I
get it it sounds pretty good let's level
stuff out why not but that does mean
that we're going to be paying 35% more
either because it's tax coming in from
Mexico or it costs much more to make
here the brain tends to solve the
problem
it looks at and when we're just looking
at how to better manufacturing for
workers obviously obviously raise those
tariffs get those factories back here
problem solved but there's always an
unintended consequence it's the same
kind of thinking that says look we we
all want to see people make a living
wage we all want to see people make ends
meet so let's just raise that minimum
wage boom problem solved nobody wants to
see people thrown out of their apartment
nobody wants to see hard-working people
displaced so let's control the rent
you're in your 50s you remember
you two both because of your personal
story but just because of the time you
lived in you remember periods where
unemployment was double-digit you know
where inflation was out of control where
the economy looked pretty bleak do you
think Millennials are facing anything
like you might have faced in your you
know in your teen years or what the
world look like or when you were their
age and what you know do they have a
future and is it better than when you
grew up in or what has to happen to kind
of make things better yeah that's a
that's a great macro question my answer
is micro yeah you know my foundation is
called micro works because I really I'm
not smart enough to speak that
holistically but I take great comfort in
finding an individual who is willing to
look at the landscape however bleak and
see opportunity right and I just think
that that's always been for sale and
good times and bad and the first time
well not the first time but the first
time as an adult that I that I was
really confronted by that was in late
2008 on Dirty Jobs when the headlines
all across the country were screaming
double-digit unemployment and every
major news story in every major newscast
started with the number of people out of
work
and everywhere I went on the show Nick
every every state all I saw were help
wanted signs and so there was this other
narrative going on in the country that
had to do with the inability to to find
people who were willing to learn a skill
that was actually in demand and I was
fascinated by how little that got
reported so in 2008 the skills gap was
officially 2.3 million jobs today it's
5.8 million that means that these are
jobs that are available for you know
that nobody is applying for nobody is
qualified for where nobody's getting
hired for right it does it gets
political and I and I never mean it to
but it's impossible to not wind up in a
political conversation when one side is
saying look at all these people who
aren't working and the other side is
saying look at all these jobs we
can't fill a reasonable person has to
say why what what's the problem is it is
it really a lack of skill could it be a
lack of will is it is it a geography
problem is it really a training problem
is it a money problem as an education
problem you know and it just you know
the left will tell you that the reason
these jobs are unfilled is because these
greedy rapacious capitalists simply
aren't paying enough and the right will
tell you the reason these jobs aren't
filled because these lazy
good-for-nothing layabouts just don't
have the work ethic required or the
ambition or perhaps we're not going to
let them starve
we're all right we're going to take care
of them you know they're making forty
forty five thousand dollars a year not
working right now in total benefits so
and so now you're in a plethora right
and now we're talking about the human
condition instead of an opportunity so
it gets it gets pretty wonky pretty
that's what you're I mean your
foundation exists to kind of match up
people who want jobs to figure out how
to get there to get to the place to get
both literally and figuratively where
the jobs are honestly you're giving me
too much credit my foundation exists
because I'm desperate to answer that
question and I can't the best way I can
is to say one person at a time if I
raise this money and I put it over here
and I create a sweat pledge and I create
a situation where you have to make a
case for yourself and then you make that
case persuasively then I get to do
something that most foundations don't do
and most scholarships don't do most
scholarships reward academia athleticism
Talent and of course need right right
we're firmly trying to reward work ethic
by simply identifying a person who any
company would love to hire I'm trying to
be on a micro level the HR department
the country secretly wishes it had so if
I can in some way qualify these people
in the same way a pre-apprenticeship
program might qualify a tradesman if we
can some in some way qualify
ethic and character and a willingness to
do the hard thing
Wow people love to support that effort
and companies love to hire that person
in most states in order to become a
barber you've got to go through you
don't hun drudes if not thousands of
hours of training which costs money and
it looks time and you know rigmarole you
go up the line you know to drive a
forklift to drive a big rig to work on
an oil rig all you know what is what's
your general sense is occupational
licensing is it is it a good thing is
that a bad thing does it get abused you
know are there on it is it being used to
keep people out to restrict the labor
supply so the guys who are on the inside
get more money or is it working the way
that it should be yes yes yes no it's a
good thing when there's something wrong
with your brain and you need a guy to
fix it or a woman to fix your brain I I
I want the person working on my brain to
have certificates on the wall that prove
their commitment to brain work the
person working on my hair it would be
awesome if they didn't destroy it but I
don't really I don't really need the
comfort you know so you know there was a
great movie
guy named Sean Malone did it was called
locked out where he talked about
licensure in Georgia I think or maybe
Alabama and they were looking at hair
braiding so you know they were profiling
a series of of black women who braided
hair and were good at it and wanted to
open their own businesses and the cost
after you got all the hours and all of
the stuff is it's close to $20,000 so
when that kind of licensure becomes a
barrier to entrepreneurship it's the
opposite of good you know when it exists
to keep a lunatic from confusing your
right and left hemisphere wearing brain
surgery it's good how do we change our
attitude towards the trades and get rid
of a lot of this 20th century baggage
that just seems to be getting in the way
now we talk you know we yell we scream
we
your shoe and look things are
technologies evolving so quickly forget
Hoover what about driverless cars run
what's going to happen the trucking
industry when it's safer to have a truck
with no driver what's going to happen
when you can license out your own car
without a driver your car could be
working for you right now and it
probably will be in five ten years you
know I parked it in with a valet so I'm
pretty sure easy delivery sealant drugs
or something yeah I hope he is so I I
don't know you know you know I love the
way that the technology though is going
to force us to answer that question I
think Huxley's we shouldn't we shouldn't
stop the technology simply because it's
forcing questions well that's a that's a
heck of a statement I'm not going to
disagree with you but Huxley said the
the greatest the greatest enemy of
freedom is total anarchy but the second
greatest enemy is total efficiency and
you know somewhere in there is this
conversation between effectiveness
versus efficiency and and part of what
you're talking about I think these
holdovers from the from the early 20th
century we just have to decide again how
we're going to set the table you know it
and and for me it's look I'm very
confusing to people who hire me
sometimes because they've looked at
dirty jobs and they've seen an anthem to
blue-collar work what they didn't see
was that was every bit as much an anthem
to entrepreneurship an opportunity and
small business and the idea that those
two things can exist as two sides of the
same coin
is confusing today in the same way that
you know Turkey
there's Trump and it's Clinton right
there's blue collar there's white collar
there's right there's innovation and
imitation I've heard people say and I
can see where they're coming from that
you romanticize physical labor or
blue-collar work and this is kind of
like the way that Settlers of the at the
moment that the Indians were fully
vanquished and they started paying
tribute to them and that is kind of a
romanticization so what you're saying is
no it actually isn't because these guys
are entrepreneurs and entrepreneurs do I
mean there's a reason they call it sweat
equity right in the beginning
of the 300 people we featured on the
show 50 were multimillionaires mm-hmm
nobody knew it because we didn't talk
about it because they were covered in
somebody else's [ __ ] you know this did
not and and our brains don't allow us to
look at a person who looks like that and
immediately equated with success that's
a problem that's a problem but it's also
another example of that dissonance the
cognitive dissonance and so I just think
the I just think it's a false choice I
think I think we're full of false
choices right a full of bad choices
honestly I think the election is a good
example but the way we process things
and the way we force the conversation
leaves us with you know protectionist or
not protectionist bro blue-collar or
white-collar well what about the money
boots architect what about what Iran
wrote about what about the person whose
collar is blue but whose whose brain is
that of a brilliant architect we
wouldn't you know those are the people
who are going to succeed I believe
moving forward and if they have a
freelance a freelance mentality then I
think they're going to succeed double
talk about that because you you talked
earlier you said about making yourself
indispensable you show up at a job site
you know and it can be in an office
building or it can be you know in a
garbage pit you don't know what you're
doing and in 18 months you make sure
you're running the joint how what is the
secret to that one of the early great
lessons I learned from my dad and my
grandfather was you you have to be
willing to do the uncomfortable thing so
it's just really so it's just it's just
a muscle if you're at a dinner party and
it's over and it's time to clean up do
it get up and start doing the dishes do
always volunteer for the scut work it it
actually is possible anybody can do that
the big lesson actually I think I think
came from the Boy Scouts where my
Scoutmaster pulled me aside at some
point and said you want the secret to
success we were having I said yeah I'll
take it he said it's not it's not enough
to simply be willing to
the hard work you have to find a way to
love it you have to find a way to like
it and to quietly congratulate yourself
and to take like real not just pride
because I I'm not sure what that word
means anymore but there's a there's
there's a nobility in it you know and
and and and the people who who think
that way and act that way not as a as a
pretence or a contrivance but because
that's just who they become
I don't know anybody like that who isn't
successful this is making me think that
somewhere along the line you read Camus
is the myth of Sisyphus and applied it
to work yeah yeah look I mean it's
making a little rocks out of big rocks
is his soul deadening and nothing in my
worldview is in defense of drudgery and
for a long time you know people used to
ask me on dirty jobs one of the things
that was so surprising about that show
is we tuned in expecting to see drudgery
because that of course is what we
associate with with so much that content
what we showed them on the show was
something else usually humour there's
great good humor in the workforce you
know and in these particular kinds of
jobs it's it's keen sometimes it's
gallows oriented but it's there and so
when you tune in expecting to see
drudgery and you see humor that was
powerful so some congressmen a couple
years ago actually introduced the good
jobs bill the hell is that what the hell
is that the good jobs bill now there's
no bad jobs bill but by implication if
we're going to sit down to talk about
the good jobs we've just hasit Lee
acknowledged a huge category of bad jobs
when we sit down to talk about the
importance of higher education
we've just tacitly confessed to the
existence of lower education now we
don't call it that because that would be
gross we call it alternative education
so the language is important the way we
set the table matters and we start
pushing kids toward an alternative
it's pretty clear that that is going to
lead to a some kind of non good job and
so suddenly we have all these vocational
consolation prizes and you don't want
your kids to have a vocational
consolation prize you want them to live
a life that's the result of a higher
education talk a little bit about what
you're trying to do with the way I heard
it and one of the recent I think one of
your very recent stories you write up
stories about people has to do with
woman named madam CJ Walker sure which i
think ties into a lot of things we've
been talking about who is she and why
did you feel a need to write a story the
way that you you know I mean the whole
idea is that you're writing stories the
way you heard it and you're telling that
yeah talk a little bit about her and
then we'll talk about your mother's
letter so madam CJ Walker was the first
female American millionaire and she was
the daughter of slaves and very few
people know this
she made her fortune because her hair
started falling out when she was 32 and
she was in a panic about it and she had
married a no-good bum and her first
husband had died very young she was
widowed she had a little girl she was
living in Vicksburg and you just
couldn't have had a grimmer deal she
moved to st. Louis and she developed a
pomade that stopped her hair from
falling out and she started making it in
her sink and she started selling it
door-to-door and this is 1900 1905
something like that for five yeah early
on so she basically creates way before
Estee Lauder or Mary Kay a kind of
direct marketing door-to-door
organization she opens hair colleges
around the country she makes a fortune
she creates 40,000 jobs her real name is
Sarah Breedlove and and the way I tell
the story or I tried to the same way I
do it with all these podcasts which by
the way is a straight-up homage to Paul
Harvey mm-hmm I'm trying to channel the
rest of the story because how many times
listening to Paul Harvey did you wind up
in your car drive you got to where you
were going
but you couldn't get out of the car
until you hear the mystery yeah so I
don't tell the viewer Sarah Breedlove is
CJ Walker I don't tell the viewer the
events are unfolding in 1905 I let
people assume it's oh five two thousand
five and so in the end hopefully you
know you have this surprise reveal where
we learned that a woman overcame some
amazing obstacles we learned that she
was the daughter of slaves we learned
that we don't know who she is you're one
of the only people I know who's hurting
from CJ Walker before but what's going
on in the 21st century where we're
having this giant conversation about
equality in the workplace and equal pay
and you know we have a women a woman
running for president or perhaps she is
by the time this airs or perhaps you
well at least she got in the game anyway
but why don't we know who CJ Walker was
the first female American winner it's a
so to me you know the way I heard it is
another opportunity for me to say here's
somebody you should know but it's a much
much much shorter format I write the
stories myself I recorded them in the
podcast world but then to your point I
sit at my kitchen table and I read them
I read them without pretense or apology
and dude I can't tell you I mean the
podcast itself is I mean it's downloaded
a few hundred thousand times a week
which is nice but the Facebook thing
sitting at my kitchen table reading a
story on Facebook millions of views know
if I got if I could get where are you
people what I do a TV show if I could
get the same people watching a TV show
that watch me read a story at my kitchen
table came over well when that drone
footage comes out I think you're gonna
go through the roof
say Mike you might get back on the the
cable Nets all right talk about the
letter from your mother because this has
got to be your biggest hit I've never
seen anything like it
and I've talked to people at Facebook
who said they've never seen they're like
my mother my mother both my parents by
the way are just pieces of work I love
him and I don't see him enough and so a
couple weeks ago she left me a couple
messages over the weekend and I was out
and I didn't call her back so in a in a
beautifully thinly veiled passive
aggressive attempt to shame me she wrote
me an email saying look if you'd prefer
to uh to talk publicly you can post what
I'm about to share with you on your
Facebook page and maybe I'll do the same
on mine I was simply calling you to tell
you that I lost my big blue person
Walmart and the ensuing events I found
somewhat humorous so she proceeded to
tell me this story in the form of a
letter that started dear Mike I read the
letter I nearly peed my pants it was one
of the funniest things I read and I
immediately set up the phone I hit
record and I read it again and then I
posted on Facebook and I went to work in
36 hours I came back and 20 million
people had watched this thing and then
the next day 45 million people had
watched it and I just looked at it again
before we sat down 110 million people
have been reached a third of the country
a third of the country watched me sit at
my kitchen table reading an email a
passive-aggressive email from my mother
so something something's happening in
the world
and again it's moms it's sons it's big
blue purses it's Walmart it's new
technology it's kitchen tables and it's
for sale and if nothing else I mean
you're you're hosting or you're making
space for a conversation that we want to
have obviously I hope you're watching
that look I hope I mean back to your
first question which I thought was kind
of brilliant you know
the degree how are we connecting and how
are we disconnected and what where are
we going socially there's so much
there's so much noise everywhere I
thought I just think people are really
really craving these honest the words
overused but authentic moments and so
you know everybody's lost their wallet
or their purse everybody's mother has
given them crap for not calling back
everybody's gotten you know a shaming
email but not everybody has puked it up
for the world to see and so that just
happened now my mother has a book deal
and in agent boy yeah we have been
talking with micro of the micro Works
foundation check them out at Facebook
check them out all over the place from
Dirty Jobs to somebody's got to do it
and to his fantastic podcast the way I
heard it Mike thanks so much for talking
to reason next time you wear the hat I
wear the coat okay or I'll wear the robe
there you go I'll make some calls for
reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie
[Music]